hello
welcome everyone to the
fifth annual uh touring lecture here at
king's college cambridge
uh thank you all for coming and thank
everyone who's online we we expect over
300
people to be participating online today
uh
so
we will have a talk and then we will
have a question and answer session so we
have we're going to have plenty of time
for questions and answers
but uh those online i think it would be
best if you if you entered your your um
questions online in the um
through the webinar interface and you
can do that anytime during the uh the
talk and then at the end of the talk
we'll have people here reading questions
uh from online
and of course you here in the audience
can participate directly um
and uh
so that's uh that's that uh
i'm going to introduce catalina kanja
who is the
she was a phd student here in computer
science and she finished her phd in
2021 last year and she's currently
working at deepmind
so catalina
[Applause]
um hello everyone thank you tim for the
introduction um it is my immense honor
and pleasure to introduce you dr ryan
hatzel today
dr hatzel is the director of research
and robotics at deepmind she also holds
an appointment at ucl and is an ellis
fellow
after taking a somewhat unconventional
route towards ai research
studying for an undergraduate degree in
religion and philosophy at reed college
dr hatzel won the outstanding
dissertation award in 2009 for her phd
thesis in machine learning
and then a few years later in 2014
she joined deepmind to work towards
building artificial general intelligence
um in her research she focuses on
continual learning for ai agents and
robots having so far produced many
approaches to solve the problem of
catastrophic
i had the great privilege of
collaborating with dr hatzel in my uh
internship at deepmind in 2020
and um our discussions and brainstorms
were
had a fundamental
impact on the course of my internship
and yeah we're very useful for for my
progress overall
so without further ado i'll now let her
tell you more about um all the exciting
and very recent research towards
building agi thank you
[Applause]
all right hello everybody can you hear
me
wonderful
um thank you so much for the
introductions tim catalina and uh very
honored to be the fifth touring lecturer
here at king's college
um it was a special honor for me to come
to king's college while my daughter is
still a a student here
been enjoying seeing king's college
through her eyes um as a student and now
i get to see it as a visiting lecturer
so um
i am
the director of research on robotics at
deepmind i've been there for about eight
years and i've seen the company
grow and change over that time and
really do some very exciting exciting
things
i wanted to talk to you a little bit
about where i think some of the ways in
which we are using
modern ai methods to solve problems
science problems history problems and
how that might have impact for all of us
in the future
i need to click right
so
first i thought it appropriate to start
with touring i really enjoyed
reading
touring's articles i had read the the
article about the imitation game
when i was
i don't know several years ago but just
recently i read his paper on
called intelligent machinery which was
never published and which he wrote in
1948
and in there he speculates about how one
might build an intelligent machine
he uses the analogy of the infant cortex
and he talks about an unorganized
machine
and how the infant cortex is trained
with data with experience and with
feedback in order to become to mod be
modified into an intelligent organized
machine and he thought that the same
might be capable if we could build such
an unorganized machine
and then to be able to train it with
data
he speculated that that some critical
components of such a machine would be
memory
would be sensory inputs
and would be the use of feedback
mechanisms such as reward or punishments
um
and this was
quite remarkable to think about this
perspective of
of what an intelligent machine could be
because in a lot of ways this is how we
think about agi now 70 years later
so a a little quote from that paper
sorry we are ecuador
uh
turin wrote
as he was thinking about how to build
this what experiments could be done how
would one build an unorganized machine
and what would the methods of
organization be once you had that
machine and he said i feel that more
should be done i would like to
investigate other types of unorganized
machines and also try out organizing
methods that are analogous to our
methods of education
i made a start but found it all together
to laborious at present
and he continues
when some electronic machines are in
actual operation i hope that they will
make this more feasible
this just this made me
sad because i wish touring could be with
us today
because a lot has changed in the 70
years since touring wrote this
um
let me talk about a few things that i
think are most important most relevant
to ai
so first of all let's start with
sorry
pointing this uh let's start with
neuroscience so
neuroscience is important you can see in
his in his writings from 1948 that the
idea of how human intelligence works
should be really relevant really
important for how we build an
intelligent machine
and in the last decades we have seen
relentless steady important
breakthroughs being made
in understanding intelligence human
intelligence mammal intelligence other
species as well
just to call out a few things there's
mapping the the human genome
it's been a huge effort obviously and
has you know probably decades more
results to come out of that
um there's been work on grid cells and
spatial navigation um this work that
i've done that i find fascinating
understanding how it is in the human
brain that we know where we are in the
world and that we know we can recognize
places know if we've been somewhere
before remember how to navigate from
here to there and are able to locate
ourselves locally in a room
in a country in the world be able to
have that understanding that's due to
structures and particular cells that we
have in the brain and in the hippocampus
which actually at least in humans are
also used for
concept development and abstract thought
and abstract reasoning so fascinating
study and a huge amount has been done in
in that area of work in the last 10
years or so and then also decoding the
visual cortex this is a nice example
because we've made a lot of progress say
we i mean neuroscientists have made a
lot of progress in understanding how the
visual system works in humans a lot by
understanding how uh computer vision
computer models of vision uh work and
comparing the two understanding how
representations are formed as one goes
from the retina through through the
different layers of the visual cortex
and that has really helped in
been helped by also looking at how we
train large computer vision models so
this has been really valuable for ai and
now in now i really see this
back and forth
neuroscientists use ai methods to
advance their research
and
ai researchers take inspiration from
neuroscience and cognitive science to
build models
compute
computation
so one has to call out this obviously
that this is what uh touring was
bemoaning not having and what we have
now in spades so gordon moore in 1975
said that the number of transistors and
resistors on a chip doubles every 24
months
it's been almost 50 years
and we are still on that path
and every year somebody says we're done
moore's law is dead
and every year we keep on going onwards
it is
amazing truly amazing moore's law means
that we have
systems like this huge distributed
compute systems that allow us to do much
more than feed youtube to all of us they
allow us to
build enormous simulators to and for the
purposes as of ai to train very large
models to store a lot of data and to
build the most unorganized
large-scale machine that touring could
possibly imagine
and last i wanted to mention ai methods
um because of course the methods for
understanding how we can build and and
how we can train that intelligent
machine
those methods of learning have changed a
lot since turin's time
so um just a few themes that i'll point
out first of all neural networks and
back propagation or gradient based
optimization um this is something that
first appeared in the 1980s
was went out of fashion for a while and
now has come back into fashion why it's
a simple method that scales really well
with the compute and moore's law i
showed on the previous slide
um
probability theory
using uh
use using bayes um approaches bayesian
approaches allow us to
understand not just what a uh what an ai
model can do but what it can't do
the very important question of how do we
assess the uncertainty of a model this
is important not only for giving giving
good answers but also for allowing
humans to interact
with these ai models
reinforcement learning this has been
again this is a concept that that's been
around for a few decades but in the last
decade what we've seen is that we can
couple
reinforcement learning mechanisms
training using positive and negative
feedback
with neural networks
in order to train for a specific um uh
for
a to solve problems that otherwise we
couldn't solve moreover we can not only
solve those problems but we can
sometimes get to superhuman performance
on those those problems
and i'll give an example later in the
talk of reinforcement learning
um and then lastly uh it just in the
in the last few years um the last ten
years or so what we've really been
seeing is the return of much much bigger
neural networks
how big are they you ask
um so
i just thought i'd i'd give you a little
um
a few examples here so
i started my phd in the early 2000s and
the first neural network that i came
into contact with um and helped train
was limet5 which was a small
convolutional neural network used to
identify handwritten digits between 0
and 9.
um it had 60 000 parameters in it which
means these are the weights that we
change as we
as as we optimize the neural network
from data
10 years later
this was about the time just before i
started at deepmind then alexnet was
released and alexnet was one of the
first
large-scale models that really
surpassed significantly state of the art
on a hard problem in this case the
problem of identifying a thousand
different types of objects in images in
imagenet it had 62 million parameters
much bigger you're still not impressed
all right 10 years later
10 years later 2022 this year um others
have released similar models but deep
mind i'll mention
release the model chinchilla
which has 70 billion parameters in it
um and this was a model that was trained
to uh simply generate language or train
to predict the next word um
through a set of
text inputs
and it has 70 billion parameters um
and that's certainly not the largest i
know that there are plenty of models
that are now in the hundreds of billions
of parameters
um so this is a
six order of magnitude increase um since
i started my phd it wasn't that long ago
all right let's go on so
um yeah i
i
wish that touring could be alive today
because i think that this is a really
exciting time for exactly his
perspective on what an intelligent
machine is can be
i'm going to take the rest of this talk
and walk through a few different
examples um
sort of case studies where we've used ai
methods
and they're arranged in
in orbit here because some of them may
seem a little bit more esoteric and some
of them may seem a little bit more
relevant so let's start at the outside
on the esoteric side
and we will talk about ancient text
restoration
any historic any historians in the room
all right
uh so this is some work um by my
colleagues uh giannis assail and teo
summershield um at deepmind and the full
paper you can read in in nature um one
of the exciting things about this work
is that it was a great collaboration
it's a collaboration between deep mind
two different google teams and then the
university of oxford athens university
and uh university of venice and i know
i'm not supposed to mention oxford but
you know to do it sometimes
so
the core problem here
um is that of understanding
inscribed texts from the distant past
and these um the the the study is
properly known as epigraphy epigraphy
not sure
and um
these texts that exist on stone stone
blocks they offer first-hand evidence
for thought for language society and
culture of civilizations that are long
gone
and there are a lot of these
inscriptions that have survived but a
lot of them look like this
is so the problem for a historian is at
least threefold
first of all the inscriptions might be
damaged and their texts lost so we want
to do text restoration
secondly those inscriptions you would
think well you found the stone here
that's where that's where it's from but
actually they can be trafficked moved
stolen lost etc um so the geographical
attribution is an important part of
puzzle and when are they from well
radiocarbon dating doesn't work on
stones especially if that uh
piece of stone has moved around you
don't have any chronological attribution
so three good puzzles we can solve them
all at once
and this is an example of the actual
restoration the output of the model that
was trained
um and i do not read a greek so i'm not
going to try to but this is a restored
decree concerning the acropolis of
athens from the 5th century bce
all right so how does this work
uh the model here is called ithaca and
it's actually available so if you are
interested in this you can look it up
and you can play with it you can feed in
your own data i believe and see what it
has to say and the way that it is
trained
is by taking data that we do know the
whole thing so luckily there's plenty of
of these stone blocks that are complete
and we know all of the information about
them
we take that perfect information
we feed it through
we feed it into the network as a stream
of characters
and
we process that through a neural network
which i'm not going to go into the
details of it's there in the paper if
you'd like to know and we ask the
network to predict three things
one what are the missing characters
we took out a few characters what are
those characters
what is the geographic attribution where
was it and thirdly when was it
now
naively one might separate these into
different problems but of course they're
all related right the where and the when
and the what of the text are all
intricately linked
so we're training for these three
different things but actually they feed
into each other and they support each
other in a really valuable way so
training this in a multi-task sort of
system made the whole the whole thing
work work better
um and then
we
out the model output output some guesses
so this starts out as a big unorganized
model an organized machine we feed in
the data sentence by sentence phrase by
phrase
we feed back through the correct answers
propagate that back through and train
the whole thing
the results
are
one of the one of the things that is is
that's valuable about this system about
ithaca is the interpretability of the
results
and uh so you can see at the top
very small pointer um you can see at the
top here that it actually produces three
possible words to go in into this blank
spot and it gives a probability a
likelihood for each of them
so that's valuable because maybe the
first answer isn't correct or maybe in
those alternate answers there's more
information there that could be valuable
for the historian
secondly it also gives out a heat map
gives out information
saliency information as to what parts of
the context were important for giving
that answer
and that also gives a way to
gives because it gives a window in to
interpret the model and understand its
outputs
so this is the output that's given for
geographical attribution for instance
you also get a distribution over
possible answers or top answers and also
you get a distribution over the
different uh
chronology
in some cases we have exact information
about what exactly that date was of that
because it may have been written on the
on on the slate as part of that or other
methods of dating it exactly
so we can assess how good these are
so just really quickly um i will mention
a few results here so on this slide
what we can see is that the ithaca model
the one that's highlighted here
does better than the models before it so
there's pithia which is a previous work
and it also does better than the human
experts
so if you compare directly human experts
and their answers to restoring the text
to giving the chronology to giving the
geography
then our model actually does better
um
across the board some of these it's good
to be low and some of these is going to
be high
doesn't matter
so ithaca does well it's not perfect but
it does really well
interesting thing though is take a look
at this line
this is what happens when you combine
the human expert with the model when you
say here's this model that we trained
take this use it learn it
just like we use
our phone just like we use you know the
different tools that we have for our
lives
just like i use a computer as a computer
scientist we give this tool to the
ancient historian and say use this
and they're able to do a better job than
the model alone or that they could then
they could do alone this may seem
may seem obvious but i think that this
is a really important way
of how we look at ai methods but how we
look at this emerging area these
emerging technologies that are going to
change a lot of the things that we work
on
in most cases i think that using these
these new models as tools
tools for a doctor tools for
a mathematician
tools for a scientist
this is where their value is
um
so
ithaca uh was trained on these ancient
greek texts um but it actually has uh
impact on any disciplines that deal with
ancient texts and any language ancient
or modern could be applied there
that's because the method is relatively
general we can just change the data that
we feed into it
so this could help with identification
and study of different types of
artifacts maybe things that might have
been uh forged or
[Music]
trafficked or that are simply newly
discovered
uh so we look forward to seeing what
impacts this continues to have on the
field of ancient
ancient epigraphy
all right next stop is something a
little bit different
plasma stabilization
didn't think i'd go there
um all right so if you are there there
may be more physicists in the room than
there were historians i'm not sure but
if you'd like to know more about this
and go into the the details then uh the
title of the paper is magnetic control
tacomac plasmids
this was a
research project over the last been
about the last three years
and it was in collaboration with epfl in
lausanne switzerland
and let me first talk about uh start off
by talking about nuclear fusion for just
a moment
uh
because this is the study of how we can
develop energy sources using nuclear
fusion
back in the 1920s there was a british
physicist
by the name of aston i believe
last name of aston and he
had the observation that four hydrogen
atoms way more have more mass
than one helium atom
the implication of this
is that
inside of the sun and other stars that
there might be a process of fusion going
on that is emitting energy
that the colliding of hydrogen atoms
form helium and throw off a neutron on
the way
that this might be responsible for the
energy that is created by stars
so
people worked about on this and thought
about this throughout the 20s the 30s in
the 1950s
there was a
conceptualization of what's known as a
takamak
which is a meta and
magnetic confinement device
where you can have a
controlled nuclear fusion
experiment that might happen where one
might be able to harness the energy from
this reaction that is happening within
within this device
and
you know that was in the 50s so same as
the touring as touring good ideas came
came up in in the 50s this is still
today seen as being the most viable and
the most practical way
to develop nuclear fusion energy
um so
let's talk a little bit more about
what's happening here um how do you fuse
two nuclei
you put them together and you push
um and the way in which you do that is
by building something like this takamak
where you create the pressure and the
heat in order to create plasma the
fourth state of of matter
where electrons and
nuclei move around and can collide and
fuse
and the way in which you control this is
by having these sets of magnetic coils
both inside and outside of this toroidal
shape
and inside of there
you try to get to a state of having this
plasma and having this fusion happen you
have to do it stably
you have to be able to do it for long
enough maintain the state of plasma so
that you get energy from it
uh so this is the this is the problem if
we look at a cross section within that
troidle uh takamak
within that containment device then this
is what you see
this is a simulator um that's running
and
what you see on the left is successfully
controlled plasma
all around the edges
we see those little numbers changing
those are different coils and that's how
you control that plasma
you try to get it to a point i always
think about this as being like you have
air jets and you're trying to keep a
balloon in the air or something right
you gotta you gotta sort of control this
thing without touching it
and so you're trying to do that with the
plasma and if you don't keep it in the
right position if you don't keep it high
enough if you don't keep it alive then
it it it falls apart or it goes unstable
bad things happen
so that's the game you want to keep the
plasma alive you want to control the
position of the plasma and you want to
control the shape of the plasma
and
the ways that you have to control it are
all of these coils that you've got going
around this and then you've also so 19
different ways to buttons that you can
press to control it and 92 different
observations that you have
the way in which
we decided to approach this is from a
robotics perspective
um so i'm the director of robotics at
deepmind one of things we do is develop
algorithms to control robots and when
you control a robot often you're
controlling a whole bunch of different
joints for instance a human robot might
have 20 or 30 different joints that
you're controlling so you're sending a
number to all of those joints very
quickly in order to control the
actuators and keep that robot moving
along
similar sort of algorithm could well
work for this
so that's what we did one of our
algorithms is called mpo
i won't go into the details of it
but that is a reinforcement learning
algorithm
it's a neural network which is trained
by doing reward maximization where the
reward
are these three different goals
how do we control and keep the plasma
alive and it took a lot of work in
simulation because they wouldn't let us
near the tacomac
for a long time
but eventually
we were actually able to make this work
so well in simulation
that we were able to run experiments on
the actual takamak and use a
deep reinforcement learning network
to control the takamak so what you see
here is the reconstruction in the
simulator the little dots around the
outside those are the observations
of it
and we don't see the different control
points
it doesn't look like a whole lot inside
of the takamak
but it worked
it was stable and successful enough in
fact what we've been able to show is
that we can create using our
reinforcement learning we can create all
of these different stable configurations
which have been known theoretically
by physicists but have been very hard to
actually
make stable in a real reactor
inside the taco map so
what we hope by working with the
scientists at epfl is that this will
open up the scope for them to have a
whole new set of tools
in this case by the way this was not a
very large neural network this was a
very small neural network
it was really just about that algorithm
about how we learn from
the
the goals and the rewards of the system
and using a neural network rather than
trying to do it from
uh
from using more traditional methods of
control optimization
all right so exciting work there for
your physicist then please check out
more about this
so
next stop on the journey
is weather
try to pick things that you know
have
a wide variety of perhaps impact on us
weather forecasting is important weather
forecasting is important because it's
step one of understanding our climate
right so when we're trying to predict
the weather for tomorrow or next week we
can also think about extrapolate out and
think about the problem of predicting
the weather
in a century
from now
so
weather forecasting this is this was a
project that we also started three or
four years ago that i've been very
involved with
and it was a collaboration with the met
office so you see a theme here i think
that a lot of our best work has been
through working with a partner on a
particular domain it takes a long time
to understand the problem understand
where the challenges are and understand
what the solutions are
in particular whether or not this is an
area that really where a solution would
be really fundamental
would be really important for the field
and important for
for humanity
so in this case
we worked with the uk met office uh
meteorological office and we identified
uh the problem that we wanted to solve
and this is called precipitation now
casting
this is the problem of
predicting whether or not it will rain
and how much it will rain
in the next 60 to 90 minutes
for a given part of the country it's not
very far in the future right it's now
casting it's the point very short window
in the future and you would think that
if we can do a reasonable job of
predicting the rain next week we should
be able to predict the rain in an hour
but actually the models that are used
that are state-of-the-art models for
for
for doing forecasting big numerical
dynamics dynamical models that are used
are not very good at adjusting to the
current data so they will stubbornly
continue to say nope it's going to be
sunny today even as the clouds are are
moving in
so
it is important to come up with a a
different type of method to think about
whether or not we can predict the rain
in in this short term
and the the output of this it's useful
for us if we want to plan a picnic
uh but it's also used by experts who
need to be able to
uh to issue flood warnings to do air
traffic control um and and marine work
uh but there are a lot of challenges
here so
uh you need to be accurate it's uh
as i said it's it's important uh
we we need that higher level of accuracy
than one than what we can get from other
approaches we also have to account for
uncertainty need to be able to give a
likelihood be able to give a probability
of rain and how much rain and the
hardest one in that list is capturing
rare events
it's not that important to know if it's
going to uh you know sprinkle in an hour
but it might be really important to know
if there's going to be a catastrophic
storm or a flood situation
and that's what's hard for data because
those events are rare and they're
strange and they're a little bit
different so capturing those anomalies
is actually
a big part of the of the challenge
uh so taking this into deep mind out of
the met office and saying all right
let's think about this problem then we
first need to think about about data
so what we focused on are these very
large
radar fields
and you can see these sort of bands of
rain crossing uk
and ireland
and what we did was think about these as
just a video right this is just a stream
of videos coming in where we get a new
frame of the video
uh every five minutes so that's 288
frames a day
um and
each pixel in the video in each frame
represents one square kilometer on the
ground so it's pretty high resolution
and we have data from 2016 onward so a
lot of that that produces a lot of data
that we can work with
now the approach that we wanted to train
the way in which we wanted to um
to to work on this was as a prediction
problem in a way it's a little bit
similar to the model i showed you for
the ancient text restoration we know all
the answers we know exactly how the rain
evolves across
you know a few hours the day well what
we want to do is to give the model part
of the information ask it to predict
what comes next
and then
feedback how well it did and train the
model that way it's a pure video
prediction problem that is conditioned
on what has happened so far
um
so with an input being
you know a few frames from this model
maybe an hour or two of data then we
want to say predict what the next frames
are going to be
but we actually need this to be a
sampling model so we want to be able to
say
to be able to say given these starting
states
given all that's happened so far give me
a bunch of possible outcomes as to what
the weather is going to do for the next
hour and a half
um because that's a one way to capture
rare events the model could produce a
bunch of likelihoods and one of those
has a has has a big uh you know a big
storm blowing up out of nowhere so it's
important to be able to to assess the
likelihood of different types of
outcomes and look at that by having
multiple different sampled realizations
of the of the future weather
um so the method that we used is
something called conditional generative
adversarial networks
it's conditional because it starts
because we give it the starting point
generate weather conditioned based on
what i'm giving you as a starting point
it's generative because we're then
generating what comes next
it's adversarial
because
we have a generator that's predicting
what's going to happen next and we have
another neural network
which is called the discriminator
which is trying to
say whether or not that generation is
good or bad
so it's a game that is played between
two neural networks
that forces the generator to get better
at what it's doing so that the
adversarial network
has a harder job telling real from take
generated outputs
some of you might know uh something
about this this general approach it's
called a gan generative um adversarial
network um and that's because it has
more typically been known for producing
deep fakes
so a generative adversarial network
again produced those four
images of people
none of them are real
those are not real people's faces those
are completely generated by a network
they are what we call deep fakes
so this type of network has also been
used to
generate false false videos false audio
false text
um i i don't think that that is a good
use of this technology
um but i don't think that the technology
is bad i think that this is a really
powerful technology and there are a lot
of ways in which it can be used for very
important things like what we've done
here in using the same technology in
order to
produce a better weather forecasting
system
i just wanted to point out that
connection that's one of the
fundamentally exciting things and
powerful things about ai methods is how
general they are and how they can be
used for very different things
all right so
i just want i will point out
you know sometimes
it's a bit abstract if i talk about
these things i just wanted to give one
one example here
um so this is actually a difficult case
it was chosen by the chief forecaster of
the uh at the met office uh
independently of the project team he
said give us a hard problem that we can
use as an evaluation
and then we ran that problem we actually
collected a whole bunch of them and we
ran it through our model and a bunch of
other baselines and the previous um
system that that the met office was
using
and came up with these different results
and we gave these to uh to
meteorologists and said
how would you use this tool how do you
like these these outputs because we
wanted their
eyes on it this should be again a tool
for them
not something
for us so in this case we have a little
storm brewing up here and you can see
how the original observation and then
you can see how it changes at uh plus 30
minutes at 60 minutes and at 90 minutes
and it evolves and changes over time and
it's a difficult to predict system
because of the
small convective cells there
and
the traditional now casting system this
is what's used by
um by the met office it's called pi
steps and this combines um those big
numerical
models with uh the actual radar sort of
extrapolated forwards using optical flow
anyway it doesn't matter too much if we
take a look at it then what we see is
that even at plus 30 minutes it's
already degraded significantly from the
ground truth above
it is hallucinating these gigantic
storms which didn't actually exist with
very intense rainfall
but more importantly it's starting to
really move the area where there's the
intensity away from where it was so even
the shape of this is no longer accurate
so i'll just compare this against our
method
which
if you look at you can certainly tell
significant differences like i said this
is a hard problem
but you can also see that the shape and
the areas of intensity are appropriate
and correct and which when we show this
to meteorologists they say that's the
one i want to use this is the thing that
i want to use if i'm going to deliver a
forecast to the fine people of
the uk
so
um this is a i think a great example of
a new approach it's ai methods and uh
generative adversarial networks scans
being brought to to bear on an old
problem
um and again this is designed to
complement not replace
human expertise
and provide decision-making value for
meteorologists
all right next stop um is something that
now this brings us
check my time brings us um even closer
to
to us i think
and this is the problem of machine
translation
when i think about machine translation i
always think about douglas adams
anyone all right good
because douglas adams had a very simple
problem for the sci-fi
challenge of you know how do you talk
about different people from different
planets coming together without dealing
with the problem of that they're not
going to speak the same language and he
said well there's something called a
babel fish you stick the babel fish in
your ear and that allows you to
immediately uh
translate from any language to any other
language
um
that was science fiction when i was
reading douglas adams as a teenager you
know what it's not science fiction
anymore i mean it's not a fish um i get
don't don't get don't get me wrong but
what we do have is um
is
is is a method built
via ai methods that can translate from
one language to another language as
quickly as you can speak
and it doesn't it's not as good as a
human translator that knows that is
bilingual and knows the two languages
intimately and can translate really well
it's not that good
but it's good enough
that i can talk to somebody i can speak
into my phone
and it will immediately translate it and
output it in another language that's
amazing
absolutely amazing
and just to give a little bit of of
insight into uh how this has developed
because this has been happening for the
last 10 years has been this revolution
in machine translation
10 years ago the way in which machine
translation worked was you started in
your source language and you wanted to
get to your target language and you had
a very very modular system with a lot of
very smart things in here this is not
trivial this is a very complex system
but the understanding was that in order
to do this well you have to understand
what it is you have to parse it and
chunk it you have to do structural
transfer you have to do target
generation you have to do all of these
different pieces of it separately
in order to get from a to b
and
what people started to do in the last 10
years is simply train a large
unorganized machine
and organize it to do the whole thing
internally
in the same way that we learn to
translate from one to the other we don't
develop separate modules in our brain to
solve the different pieces of it in an
analytical way
instead we learn from data and we figure
out and of course internally we're
probably still doing the chunking and
the parsing and structural pieces of etc
but it's
optimized much much better if we can do
it end to end from one to the other
using a lot of data and a large neural
network
um so this this has been what's what's
been happening and it works really well
i thought that i might um oh and and one
more piece of it which is um wavenet so
this is a separate part wavenet is an
approach
uh for generating audio
so for a long time machine translation
was just something that happened in text
but you wouldn't have it actually you
wouldn't have um the system tried to
speak to you
because it wouldn't come out
um
wouldn't come out sounding very good it
would end up coming out sounding like a
robot um
and wavenet is an approach that was
developed to generate raw audio it is a
generative network and the interesting
thing here is that
it predicts each individual
millisecond of that audio waveform one
by one in a sequence
and
you know nobody really thought that this
was possible or that this would work
well and it worked surprisingly well
so conditioned on a piece of text that
you want it to say
train this approach and you output audio
that sounds pretty good um
probably not perfectly like a human but
i believe it has the gap to human
sounding audio let me i just thought i'd
give you an example of this this is
something that any of you can do if you
go to google translate
or other translate apps but
i
put together an example
you can go ahead and start this i wanted
to try translating english into french
and then i translated the avocado is a
pear-shaped fruit with leathery skin
smooth edible flesh and a large
you
the avocado is a pear-shaped fruit with
leathery skin smooth edible flesh and a
large stone
all right so
i think that's pretty darn neat
it makes it very hard for me to convince
my son that he should still take
languages in high school um but that's
that's that's a different problem but i
think that the um
being able to speak to my phone
have it find the words correctly
immediately turn it into two different
languages and speak it back in a legible
form is it perfect probably not and if
any of you are speak danish then i would
love to know if it's accurate or not
um
but
but it does awfully well this is a
really really powerful technology
and very exciting to me all right i am
running out of time so i will move ahead
and just say briefly about uh say
something about what is perhaps on the
horizon
um and i wanted to talk about two things
quickly
one is language models as the future of
search so what is a language model so i
talked to i mentioned chinchilla and
it's 70 billion parameters that is a
language model it is a large model
trained on
all of the web or at least all of the
english text on the web
and
the way it's trained is very simple
predict the next word
given a sequence of text what's the next
word
um so that fill in the blank way of
training a network very powerful when
you've got a very large model and a lot
of data these models have gotten so good
that
they you can have a conversation with
them
and they can say meaningful things and
they can access what they have been
trained on which is a lot of data in the
world now there's a lot of work to be
done here but i think that this will
become in the in
in not too many more years
the next step for search so just like
now you can go to the the search engine
of your choice
and look up things and get a listing of
results
now what you'll be able to do is talk to
an expert that search will still be
valuable but what if you want to ask
questions about the about ancient greek
transcriptions
or about running a marathon
or about
giraffes
you would be able to take this language
model and it will have within it all of
those
experts and
the work that needs to be done is about
making sure that that information is all
verifiable correct and you can
understand where did this come from why
did you give me this answer but it will
be able to have that depth of expertise
and the ability to explain
which will make it very powerful not
everybody can come to cambridge go to
university here
this will be something that everybody
will be able to have
just like everybody
has access now to search engines to look
up basic facts about the world now
people will start to have
the ability to know so much more
about their world
gain that knowledge gain that
information i think it will be important
important for the world important for
democracy
that's one thing
coming soon
to our world and the second one i will
point out is robotics i have to talk
about robots we knew that they would be
in here somewhere
um
so robotics is difficult i could give
whole talk i have given whole talks on
why robotics is hard
and why robotics as a field has not had
quite the same transformations as we've
seen in some other fields because of of
ai such as machine translation
um
i won't go into all of those those
aspects of why it's challenging but i do
think that
what we are going to start to see is
that robots currently can only be in
factories and very very controlled
environments that usable robots are
going to start to
be come into human spaces and be able to
work with humans be able to support
humans on the things that we do in the
world
so by that i mean let's think about
construction
humans do construction it is something
that is dangerous it's hard it's
repetitive
and i'm not saying that humans shouldn't
do construction i'm saying humans should
have a robot to help
saying that if we can develop robots
that can be safely in the world with
people that can help with things like
this in a general way
that will be incredibly powerful for the
sort of work that we can do and for us
being able to be safer in our jobs
machines have been giving humans that
ability for a long time to be able to
be at a
to be a little bit safer
and to be a little bit more comfortable
and i think that robots will do the same
thing in agriculture i think it will
have the same impact but we need robots
that are general enough that can
interact with humans and that can
support humans in what they do
and the same thing with dealing with the
debris of the world
perhaps some of you have seen the movie
wall-e
i think that that was a a
visionary movie because i think that we
will end up in a world where we have
robots that can deal with hopefully not
quite that world it's a little bit
post-apocalyptic but
be able to have robots that can deal
with
the garbage the recycling things around
us
so that we don't have to
all right um and just lastly i want to
say that i'm very happy that um i
haven't said too much about about deep
mind
i do have a lot of faith that the work
that we do we think very carefully about
how to do work we collaborate with
others we collaborate with experts and i
think that responsible responsibility is
the most important thing for me in terms
of developing
these future tools and technologies
all right that is a list of uh the
different some of the different work
that i talked about um if you want to
learn anything more about them please
feel free to look those up and thank you
very much
[Applause]
thank you very much for a wonderful talk
and it's time for questions
uh so who would like to ask the first
question
uh jamie do you have an online question
oh we have a question oh i'm sorry and
do we have a microphone
uh hold on a second we're gonna get this
microphone that we pass around
so that the people online can hear you
yeah that's the thing
the online audience won't be able to
hear you unless you have a microphone
there we go
it's a
how long does the experiment last
uh so the way in which the the research
facility the the this is run it is a
three second run
no it's not um
[Music]
to be honest though the
the uh three seconds was dictated by uh
the
um
by the researchers and how they they run
the facility um and obviously we need to
have a lot of confidence in what will
happen if it is run for longer but
absolutely it still is run for
three seconds and then requires 15
minutes
um in order to recharge in order to have
the next three second run so we still
have a lot of work to do
um
[Music]
was it a deep mind talk or a google
[Music]
um it's quite possible i know that there
was a previous work um that was that
came out of the same group and was also
focused on this this is something that
giannis the first author has been
working on for several years um but i
don't know particularly
we have one online question
okay i'll do that until we get the
microphone fixed yeah well this question
is asking about
ideas and thinking about the minds of
children
[Music]
the question asked
was whether or not turing had ideas
about how reward or punishment feedback
could be used um in the training of
systems
he
i mean i would suggest that people read
the 1948 article it's called intelligent
machinery um it there's only a brief
section however on the use of rewards
and it falls short of developing rewards
as an objective function as we use it
now
or thinking specifically about reward
maximization
more generally it was about if you
if the machine if you insert random
inputs then you will get a range of
different outputs and that you could use
a notion of reward or punishment in
order to select between those and
suppress some of those so it's a way to
modify the behavior
but there really wasn't the notion there
of
of using something like gradient
presenter this type of optimization that
we use now but really more matter of um
after you have done exploration how do
you choose how do you uh choose the best
and worst outcomes though
we have a question right here
it's a great it's a great question we
need to repeat it first would you like
to repeat it
i don't think i can
maybe you could incorporate it in your
answer
the question was about weather
forecasting and what it is exactly that
we're doing with our neural networks
that somehow avoids the challenges of
the the dynamical systems uh that run uh
the partial differential equations and
simulate the
the weather um and
um
the the answer is
so we have explored a lot of different
possibilities because one of the very
interesting
ways to approach this is to say we know
a lot about the physical constraints
that must be happening we know a lot
about the weather and how you know
what's happening in the in the
atmosphere we can simulate a lot of that
really well so can we put together
these well understood
physical systems with something that is
that is learned from data
because even though that even though uh
that
numerical model of the weather is very
good
of course there's lots of things that
are not observed
and all of those errors in the
observation mean that the model is wrong
the model says it is raining but it is
not so
how can we combine data from
observations um with this and come up
with something that's a little bit
better so that was that's one approach
um very generally
that we have worked on what we have
found to work better
is simply using data we treat this as a
problem of pixels coming in
and pixels coming out
we look at the past and we predict the
future and we would do it
the same way no matter what type of
video it is in this case the video
happens to be this layer of radar
information right precipitation
information from radar
moving across
um
the
moving across the the earth and what
this means is that the ants what we
predict
may be really wrong and in fact it is
when the model starts out the model says
oh the rain just turns corner and goes
that way and does something wacky it's
not obeying physical constraints but by
observing a lot of data training on a
lot of data it becomes more and more and
more accurate to the point where it's
more accurate
than the
um
than the partially differentiable
equations
that don't have all of the that don't
have all the information so um
essentially what the system is is a
uh neural network that sees we feed in
say 10 frames
of data
over time and then we start to output
frames after that
and then we
um and the neural network is a pretty
big neural network
maybe 20 layers in it
um probably uh
maybe a billion parameters i don't
actually know for sure what the final
model is and then when we get an answer
is this wrong is is this right then we
use gradient descent and we
back propagate that error information
back through the network
um that's that's that's how it works um
and
with enough data
it becomes extremely good at solving
that problem
if you roll it forward too far you try
to say can i predict the next day of
weather
then
it falls it falls apart right and then
the numerical method is doing better it
can simulate the dynamics of the weather
better over a long term period but for
that first hour or two this method is
better
thank you uh we have some online
questions
i'll i'll let jamie uh read those
um yeah so we have a question from tai
yang online he's saying do we today have
a good theoretical foundation a
theoretical understanding
of what's going on in these
fantastically successful models that
you've shown us
or is it still or is it still magic
asked by a theoretician
um
so there is always uh a lot
i think more work to be done on sort of
the more fun foundational questions um
and understanding from a theoretical
point what's going on we do understand a
lot um it's certainly not magic do we
understand everything are there things
that still surprise us um no and yes uh
but
you know the the this is why the field
has grown substantially because it's not
just about people uh
seeing how many billions of parameters
they can they can train all at once on
how many different machines using how
much data it's much more than that it's
understanding a lot of different things
how we um how the optimization works
what bad optimization looks like what
underfitting looks like overfitting et
cetera a lot of those start to to become
much more about the the fundamental
questions of uh how is the network
trained um theoret
the the theory of capacity of networks
um and these sorts of
ways of understanding it
you know computer science is a really is
a really rich field and i don't think
that we can say that we are ever done
with sort of the theoretical aspects of
it um nor with the more applied and
empirical side of it
okay we'll take a another question from
online
um yeah this question is from tassine i
shackly online
uh he writes thank you dr hadsall do you
think it's possible to build an embodied
ai of real general intelligence without
the machine having some sort of
consciousness
i wish i could ask the person online if
they would please define consciousness
um but that's the problem with answering
questions that uh come from
um
so
do i think that is it possible to build
an embodied
um agent
that would have general intelligence and
would not have consciousness
um or presumably self-awareness
be another way to state that
to me that i would go back to the
neuroscience side of this and say it's
important to start to have a really
modern understanding of what
consciousness is what self-awareness is
when i think about consciousness i think
about
having awareness of the past
and being able to predict the future
that means that i understand my state in
the world i'm not just a reactive
machine
and what we see is that that
understanding that if you look at
animals for instance that we identify
more intelligent animals as those that
have a longer memory
like elephants and are able to predict
further into the future in order to
change their actions so when i think
about consciousness i don't think about
it being on or off one thing you know is
it there is it not have you passed the
spot test any of these things what i
think about it is instead is this range
of awareness of where you are in the
world your power over making decisions
that will affect your future and using
your past in order to affect that
decision-making and that is something
that i think absolutely intelligent
machines
will have will need to have
remember that memory was one of
touring's critical components as well
okay here's a question from our
our live audience
uh thank you very much thank you very
much indeed for your your lecture i
noticed it you you made a couple of
value judgments in what was in what
one was
when you pointed to those
faked photographs of people and said
that's a bad use of technology and the
other was at the end when in your
penultimate slide you you said that the
advances towards these horizons needed
to be made responsibly and fairly
so my question is do you have anything
to say about governance of
all of these developments within your
thinking of about
techniques and
and so forth and theory
or would you say this is just a question
for legislators and nothing to do with
people like yourself
yeah very good question and um i would
have dwelled a little bit longer on that
slide but i since that i was running
short on time um but this this is an
area that i i feel quite quite strongly
about um you're right that i pointed to
the deep fakes and said this is not a
good use on the other hand hollywood
would disagree with me right i mean the
use of exactly this technology in
hollywood is blowing up it's very
important i think that there are good
uses for for all of the technology that
we build um
i think that it's it's um but that
doesn't mean that we don't have
responsibility we can't just make
technology make new things and say oh
how surprising um that is used for this
i work on robotics it's very important
to think really carefully about what is
being enabled robotics is a classic dual
use sort of technology um you can use it
to rescue people you can put a gun on it
and so you need to think about where are
the risks and are the safeguards in
place where they should be
that has to happen at multiple levels
regulation legislation has to be part of
that
and what we've seen
internationally in the last few years is
countries starting to say
we need a policy on ai we need to start
thinking about this and we need to start
doing the hard work of thinking about
what's going to happen how do we
how do we regulate this or how do we put
in guidelines but the responsibility has
to go a few steps lower than that as
well
um i think it should come in academia as
we teach students um to be
how to use data
how to think about applications how to
think about human data human
interactions
how bias is being built into the models
so this is something that needs to come
in as we learn how to be technologists
and scientists
um and
you know also from my point of view as a
senior scientist my role is is somewhere
somewhere in between the two i help deep
mind um internally to decide whether or
not enough work has gone into something
whether or not the right questions have
been asked the right mitigations have
been put into place if there is risks
etc so i'm you know for me that is um
thinking about ai uh as something that
where we all have some responsibility
people who touch it in different ways
like i said
education
users and
startups you know startups need to take
it seriously
i get very frustrated with really
irresponsible startups big companies
like deepmind google
meta etc need to take this seriously and
it also needs to be worked on at the
governmental level as well um
but that doesn't mean that we shouldn't
have these these technologies are are
wonderful powerful exciting things
um
i think that that doesn't mean we should
shut things down
just understand the risks
our penultimate question okay well thank
you for
thank you for a very stimulating talk um
i i have sort of two points to make one
of them is the computers seem sort of
iterative they just sequentially go
through all the information but is there
a role for judgment and discernment in
the machinery or is that up to the
humans
i mean i think that's probably what
we've been touching on the question of
judgment discernment what's right what's
wrong
that's the first point okay interesting
question um
i think that
there is a lot of ways in which
humans should be interacting so a lot of
the time we are training on a lot of
data there is not room in that training
process to bring in a human into the
loop in the training process especially
at these really big neural networks when
you're training something with 70
billion parameters on all of the english
text on the internet that is a process
that humans should not be involved in
because it is a very it's a it's a
massive operation but that doesn't mean
that we cannot then take that product
and be uh and interact with it as humans
um
[Music]
so that's sort of the the large models
trained on a lot of data just for the
purpose of of making that process
efficient enough um it already takes
weeks or even months
that needs to happen in sort of a very
optimized fashion
but there's other types of algorithms
for instance reinforcement algorithms
where we are actually interacting with
the robot as it learns with the system
as it learns and where human interaction
to guide that process is very much a fun
fundamental part of training
um so we've got some great work in in
robotics where humans are part of the
training process to identify um you know
how the robot should be solving a
particular task um and and and i think
that uh
that that type of work that
that that's where that's where humans
come in
um and for other models it's other
things so i don't think there's just
sort of uh one answer but certainly
human interaction with ai technologies
is is a fundamental part of what we're
building
my second point is a robotics point um
i'm a classicist and i've been working
on the new materialism which argues that
material objects things have actually um
a re an activity that they're alive in
some way
and i just wanted to
point out the robots in homer there are
robots in in hebfeistus's um
um workshop there are these maidens
these metallic maidens that move and
obey the gods and i just thought that
might be of interest
um they don't seem to have any judgment
or are they intelligent we just don't
know
very interesting thank you
so our very last question unfortunately
we're running out of time so one more
question from the online audience
this question is from adam barker
and he asks online um you've talked
about these wonderful models where we
train our systems with data but what
about situations where we fundamentally
lack data where we want to train our ai
systems to potentially handle unexpected
situations where there's just no chance
that they've seen enough data how can
these sorts of models possibly handle
those sorts of situations
yeah it's a great it's a great question
in some areas we have scads of data
but in other areas then data is very
sparse or the data that we want to to
study might be very rare like when we
are studying anomalies for instance
i wouldn't say that there's a really
that there's a single answer to this
there's more of a
toolbox
of of tools and tricks of the trade and
such
so we use simulation a lot simulation is
often the way in which we get off the
get get a system off the ground
and then we could maybe switch to
training on adding in real data
um
one also uses data augmentation a lot
where you take that little bit of real
data that you have and you expand it by
making copies of the data for instance
what if you're trying to identify
an a particular type of storm in our in
our weather problem but you've only seen
that storm you know
twice that type of of um
[Music]
of event a couple of times in the last
three years well what you can do is
change that a little bit you can move it
you can adapt it in some ways in your
data set so that it looks like it's
something a little bit different
and that gives you a way to train on
something that's very rare you make it a
little bit less rare
so that's that's the general practice of
data augmentation that's really powerful
so
there's there's not a magic
uh cure here these models do require a
lot of data there's no way to get that
performance without having a lot of data
but simulation data augmentation other
clever ways of increasing the data can
be really helpful
okay thank you i think it's time
for us to thank our speaker
once more
[Applause]
you